lo que tenemos en esta tabla son todos
los números del 1 al 100 organizados de
una manera bastante clara esta es una
forma bastante intuitiva de organizarlos
en cada renglón hay 10 números por lo
que pasa del 1 al 10 luego del 11 al 20
después del 21 al 30 hasta llegar al 100
lo que vamos a hacer es observar los
interesantes patrones que surgen de esto
si observamos lo que está resaltado aquí
en color púrpura qué números son pausa
en el vídeo y piensen en ello lo que
está resaltado son los números pares y
podemos ver que los números pares forman
estas bonitas columnas en la tabla
podemos observar esto y detectar
patrones inmediatamente por ejemplo qué
números siempre aparecen en la posición
de las unidades en los números
resaltados en la tabla podemos ver que
pueden tener un 2 en la posición de las
unidades o tienen un 4 o un 6 o un 8 o
un 0 por lo que el dígito que está en la
posición de las unidades siempre será un
número par veamos otro ejemplo
aquí están resaltados números diferentes
pausa en el vídeo y piensen en qué es lo
que se cumple para todos estos números
resaltados quizá noten que todos estos
números son múltiplos de 5 5 10 15 20 25
30 35 40 y así sucesivamente estos
forman estas dos columnas en la tabla y
aquí podemos ver claramente que los
múltiplos de 5 van a tener un 5 en la
posición de las unidades como vemos aquí
o van a tener un cero en esa posición
quizás ya sabían de esto antes pero aquí
lo pueden ver con claridad en estas dos
columnas veamos otro ejemplo este es muy
interesante porque no es solo un patrón
sencillo en columna parece que comienza
en 1 y luego sigue en esta diagonal y
termina con el 100 que patrón puede
describir el que pasen de un número a
otro como se muestra en la tabla otra
forma de decir esto es cuál es la regla
que justifica el que estos números estén
resaltados en púrpura pausa en el vídeo
y piensen en esto
una forma de pensar en esto es que si
pasamos de 1 a 10 sumamos 9 para pasar
de 10 a 19 agregamos 9 para pasar de 19
a 28 también agregamos 9 por lo que cada
número es igual a 9 más el número
anterior y al llegar al 91 91 9 es igual
a 100 aquí es importante notar que estos
no son múltiplos de 9 porque comenzamos
en 1 no en 0 si hubiéramos comenzado en
cero sería 09 18 27 y así sucesivamente
sería 9 18 27 36 45 54 63 72 81 que son
los múltiplos de 9 pero todo se desplazó
porque comenzamos en 1 y no en 0 por lo
que quedó 110 19 28 y todo lo que está
en esta diagonal hasta llegar a 100 esto
es algo muy interesante porque una forma
de pensar en esto es que todos son los
múltiplos de 9 más 1 o que si comenzamos
en 1 y seguimos sumando 9 esto
los números que resaltamos pero pueden
notar un patrón siempre que sume 9 a un
número el valor del número en la
posición de las unidades disminuye en 1
pueden verlo aquí
conforme bajamos en esta diagonal 9 8 7
6 5 4 3 2 y 1 e incluso aquí arriba
comenzamos en cero pero no hay un dígito
menor que cero por lo que regresa a
nueve es cero luego sube a nueve y de
ahí disminuye hasta que llega nuevamente
a cero y luego comienza a disminuir de
nuevo a partir de ahí nuevamente estos
son patrones interesantes que surgen en
esta tabla los invito a que la observen
y traten de encontrar sus propios
patrones